he's a legend yeah he is  [Music]  princes older half-brother Alfred  Jackson remembers him the first family  member to speak since the singer's death  did you all ever used to play together  or sing together in my mother's house in  the basement there was a piano and she  says Alfred go down there and play your  p.m. and go down there and hear no  imprints what comes out of there and do  it faster than me and do it better so  from a young kid he was always like that  Alfred had not seen or spoken to Prince  in 15 years but he has fond memories et  has learned Alfred and his siblings  gathered for a meeting Thursday to  discuss Prince's estate the singer did  not have a will Alfred's lawyer tells us  the estate could be divided equally  between the singer siblings half-blood  or for blood they take as though they  were all of natural blood or one would  not take anymore than the other so if  they're three four five six different  siblings then all siblings will take the  same